la parole est à monsieur jacques gamblin
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur mis sur
l'agriculture monsieur le ministre
hier mon collègue udi thierry benoit
vous à alerter sur la situation des
filières élevage votre réponse
superlatifs quant à l'action
gouvernementale relever davantage de la
communication que de l'action vous
n'avez rassuré personne
en fait la situation est très grave vous
en doutez allez donc sur le site
internet de la fnsea
dès la page d'accueil deux rubriques
attire l'oeil première rubrique
exploitants agricoles
comment bénéficier du rsa et oui
deuxième rubrique à partir du 2 juillet
série d'actions afin de montrer la
détresse de l'agriculture française
détresse et un mot fort mesdames et
messieurs et pour cause
aujourd'hui 30 % des exploitants
français voient arriver à grands pas la
faillite
cette situation n'est pas seulement
comme vous le dites monsieur le ministre
un problème de marché ou de crise
internationale
l'inefficacité de l'action
gouvernementale est également en cause
prenons par exemple la mise en oeuvre de
la pac en france le gouvernement a fait
le choix de l'agro écologie et de ses
contraintes
en utilisant une partie des fonds
européens à cette fin soit pour le
moment les contraintes sont là mais
d'argent point puisque selon certaines
sources 17 des 22 dossiers régionaux
français déposée à bruxelles sont
ajournées pour complément d'information
pendant qu'en pologne en allemagne tout
roule depuis février en france au 1er
juillet on est encore dans le flou ce
résultat ce n'est pas l'europe c'est
vous monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous vous en expliquer je laisse
le mot de la fin à une jeune femme
président des jeunes agriculteurs de mon
département
comment voulez-vous parler
d'installation quand tout va mal
tout est dit dans ce soupir monsieur le
ministre merci la parole est à me dire
tu es fan le foll miniser agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
ce président est monsieur députés dans
votre question vous avez cherché bien
sûr a attaqué la politique qui a été
conduite c'est normal vous êtes dans
l'opposition faudrait-il monsieur le
député que vous ayez à partir de là la
clarté et la cohérence dans la question
vous avez parlé de la réforme de la
politique agricole commune contrairement
à ce que vous avez 10 9 milliards
d'euros vont être distribués et une
partie de ses neuf il ya est liée à la
régionalisation du 2e pilier
je vous rappelle que l'accord pour la
distribution du 2e pilier et le
versement des aides étaient liés
effectivement un accord de la commission
européenne sur les plans de
développement régionaux qui ont été
déposées cet accord a été donné la
semaine dernière
je rajoute d'ailleurs monsieur le député
parce que vous avez omis de le dire que
toutes les politiques en particulier
d'installation était mise en oeuvre quoi
qu'il arrive sans signature de l'europe
puisque l'état faisait tout d avance sur
toutes les dotations jeunes agriculteurs
dès le début février et contrairement à
ce que vous dites
ne croyez pas que dans les autres pays
aujourd'hui la mise en oeuvre de la pac
soit facile ou soit réglé bien au
contraire partout les difficultés sont
rencontrées
dernier point sur la question des prix
oui il ya un problème sur les marchés et
ce matin d'ailleurs dans un journal qui
parle d'économie on avait une analyse de
la situation du marché du lait donc vous
ne contestez pas vous dites que je n'ai
rien fait et là vous avez une un prisme
un peu délicat parce que j'ai réunis et
je me suis engagé à agir dans des
négociations commerciales ou normalement
le ministre n'a pas autorité pour
décider du niveau des prix je les fais
parce que je considère qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas rester avec ses baisses de
prix qui touche directement la
production et l'élevage en particulier
donc j'annonce à la représentation
nationale que le médiateur devra suivre
l'ensemble des discussions qui ont eu
lieu et des décisions qui ont été prises
monsieur jacob à la fois par la grande
distribution et lançant des
transformateurs dans lequel il ya des
coopératives
merci